well alex curt gentlemen welcome to the
forge
this is a competition we are calling
gladiators of the forge we're going to
start off today with the two of you
going head-to-head in a fortune
competition we've got 10 weapons here on
the wall of roman weapons make your
choice
i like the look of that folks that looks
like a fun build fox all right
the folks are the fierce first century
weapon used by dacian and thracian
warriors enemies of rome hailing from
modern day eastern europe
this unique sword features a forward
curved blade sharpened on the inside
that was designed to deliver deadly
slashes and cuts upon any enemy in its
path
the fox was so lethal the romans adapted
their armor to help protect their
soldiers from its devastating blows
now alex you got to choose the weapon
kurt that means you get to choose the
forge welding technique that you both
must use
i don't do a whole lot of long blades so
i want something that i'm comfortable
with what do you got let's do uh twisted
damascus all right twisted damascus good
luck stay sharp your time starts now
i've never done twist damascus before
but i'm pretty confident i can handle it
as a queer gentleman a big part of
coming here for me is showing the world
that it's cool to be a flamboyant queer
who pounds hot steel and then goes home
and paints your nails does your makeup
and you know enjoy some delights that
the world offers
it looks like alex billet is starting to
consolidate and his welds are sticking
yeah
i've got the weld set
i'm drawing things out oh you're
beautiful beautiful bro i'm feeling
pretty good so now i'm ready to twist
this is a real do or die moment that
twist damascus is a big hurdle because
to end up with a sword you need to have
a big billet so twisting a big billet is
a pain in the neck it's time to quench
alex wedge
oh that's fighting
if my blade isn't hardened it's not a
blade and it doesn't meet parameters
gonna have to re-punch
just the way it goes
i hope this works out
there we go
all right alex just quenched for a
second time
oh yeah much better now i've got a
hardened blade start working on my
handle my plan right now is a two-piece
handle construction because the example
had a two-piece handle and i want to put
a nod to that i think my blade will make
it to the end
my plan for the billet is to start with
20 layers cut the billet in half so i
can get to 40 layers that will help me
really make the blade stand out
it looks like the forged welds have
taken i'm extremely happy so now i just
need to begin stretching this billet out
i want to get enough twists that you
really get to see that nice twist
pattern however if i twist too much
there's a chance that i end up cutting
the billet in half now i can start
working on shaping the blade
so now that i have the billet drawn to a
length that i'm comfortable with i begin
putting that curve in the blade and get
ready for heat treat
curt is in the oil now we have two quest
blades after the clutch i start working
on the finishing profile getting
everything to that final shape i am
really happy with the pattern and now i
just have to add the handle
five
four
three
two
one bite smith turn off the machines put
down your tools the first round of our
gladiator competition is over
i am really proud of what i accomplished
i'm there to win
75 000
i really got to make it all the way
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
our gladiator armor chop
alex you're up first you ready to go man
for honor for glory and for advancement
in this bladesmithing competition lay on
i will do that
nice job alex thank you jay
your blade's still straight
i love twist damascus but the problem is
you can't see it at all on your blade
you got a couple little rolls on the
edge
nothing major
everything's still tight
you do have a bit of an offset on your
tip now but for a beating like that
that's not too bad so overall
good job thank you
all right kurt how you feeling man
uh
go for it
i can do that
[Music]
all right
good job kerr you survived
first off love the damascus pattern this
came out very nice
you've got several delaminations
but nothing came apart
you got some dings and some dulling
created here at that sweet spot where it
took most of the abuse but overall it
stayed together nothing came loose nice
job thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the fish slice
alex you're up first you ready
lay on all right
[Music]
all right now let's talk about your
folks your blade's a little bit offset
from that strength test but your edge is
sharp it's got a nice feel to it and
overall sir
cool cut
thank you doug
curt your turns are you ready fly some
fish let's do this
[Music]
so
all right kurt talk about your fox right
here it's got a wider blade right here
that it actually helps support the edge
when i'm cutting i can feel the push
into the cut
you still have those delaminations but
they were not a factor in cutting the
fish overall sir your weapon
heel cut thank you doug
guys congratulations you made it through
both the tests with flying colors gave a
very difficult decision to our judges
because both your blades were great but
they made a final decision the first
ever
gladiator forge taking home five
thousand dollars is
kurt congratulations congratulations man
thank you come on
you deserve it you did an awesome job
uh alex we want to say thank you so much
for coming out and fighting hard but
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor it's a
curt
you better not go out like a chump man
but kirk you are the first gladiator to
forge and you've got a check for five
thousand dollars coming your way
congratulations
thank you
i'm officially the gladiator of the
forge
now that i've tasted that little bit of
victory i can't wait for more i feel
confident that i'll be able to take this
all the way to the end
you